all right so how often cuz Maryland is a
place that I have some real family like
my whole family's from and I've never
been there they like my grandma's from
Laurel I got family in Ocean City I got
family in Annapolis yeah uh I have
family all over Maryland that's crazy
they just I've never been you gotta go I
know I need to go and now that I live on
the sides crocheting book but now like
how often you go back to Maryland and
what can you every place it kind of has
its you know like it's it's it's unique
cultural you know I don't want to say
you know I get exactly what you're
saying what's something about Marilyn
that you know makes Marilyn what it is
you know it's really funny it's very
multicultural there's it almost in a way
it's like besides those ugly-ass Under
Armour jerseys at the trophies it's very
I don't know man it's like I think the
only thing that Mara is really known for
is like crabs and I don't mean it's a
great crabs yeah I mean actually I've
heard about the crabs yeah which is
[__] [__] but anyway besides it's
just so multi multicultural you know you
have a lot of Hispanics and blacks and
whites and you know everybody's kind of
mixed up in the pot majority of the
Hispanic community is from El Salvador a
lot of them no it's cool man I mean this
dope so it's an ms-13 definitely not but
yeah it's it's it's I mean I love where
I'm from but I usually only make it
about once a year or maybe twice a year
I should go back when I when I tour
talker huh because you know now my life
is with my team and my team is in LA and
that's what I mean is there something to
be said with what I mean somehow I
always say man is like everyone always
is like blood is thicker than anything
but like to meet loyalty man yeah I come
from really fucked-up family right
and you know the people on his tour bus
they're my family for sure and you know
the family that I grew up with I love
them
we're cool everything is straight you
know I mean but I was never it's really
weird my whole life growing up situation
was really different because I was like
only child between my mom and my dad and
then I grew up with just my mom for a
while but then all my family was there
like Oh like for my brothers from my
mom's side lived with us for a while
then I lived with my dad for a while and
then you know so it was all it was
really weird you know it like kind of
being raised in a black household
because you're around all these people
but then also being by myself for many
years with just my mom so it was
definitely really crazy
yeah if y'all if y'all go check out his
interviewer Rosenberg man he really
breaks down his family situation real
kosher super dope [__] I just had
something else to bring up but okay look
before we had that interview yeah I
think the last time we spoke I want to
say you talked about your top five
favorite albums of all time
yeah something like that you since you
are an OID guy can we talk about your
top five underrated MCS of all time and
and the top five producers of all time
okay here we go now these are personal
no this is yes is personal off the break
number one underrated underrated emcee
of all time shout out my homie Nick huff
it hard on TV black thoughts okay
from roots oh [__] day that's a
[__] that's that you you're 100%
correct man Cormega Cormega in New York
City Izzy's another way he's super dope
the realness such a great oh yeah he's
[__] crazy I'm trying to thank Sean
price is really good there's a lot of
section there's a lot there's a lot of
cats from digging into crates OD ITC oh
come on
thick think oh that's amazing dumb I
mean no record [__] what's his name
that one dude he's like Hispanic there's
there's AG is AG there's Lauren S&H and
he's like back in the Bears big L
there's Fat Joe there's
listen and so yeah it's been a wandering
one in the comments feel free to [__] on
us without knowing all the [__]
members of dignities
such a great read he has my she was
super underrated I mean you have black
thought really is the epitome yeah black
dodge number one it's just we did cuz I
don't understand
and it's funny cuz he's like on a ready
but he's so winning he's on national
[__] television every night with any
food from beer like honestly I think I
think tec-9 gets a lot of oh yeah but I
don't know I wouldn't necessarily say
that he's under great because everybody
knows that not everybody knows who he is
here right and he's got fans he's got
this I think he's just not necessarily
on the [__] like the like the pop or
you everybody did you ever listen like
the late master a [__]
tasawur Doug yeah Massa a special hot
summer you ever listen Africa right oh
come on yeah
I'll Ferrara was like I forget he did a
joint this monistic I remember seeing
him in LA he opened up for dilated
peoples at their expansion team album
release party and he was also karate
[__] I think he's gonna song with jizz a
slug shouts lads just love all day but I
would even necessarily say that he's
also underrated you know what it's funny
there's like this weird thing in hip-hop
there's like where you're like
underground or you're like really no or
this or that but I almost don't even
necessarily see atmosphere and slug has
underground because everybody knows who
they are it mean there's a certain and
throw their festival every year yeah and
everybody goes I think it's just it's
kind of like a I mean in that vein
brother leaves very enduring their
brother Ali's very oh yeah brother Lee
for sure but Black Thought [__] the
Black Thought statement cannot be said
enough I'm still wait I hope someone
leaks the black thoughts on those was a
come out also I have a I have a record
with slow nobody knows that
really yeah now you know it it's not out
yet it's not out yet what's coming up
yeah I just thought I would tell you
that now is that an on Logic record is
that happens fearless illogic record
Touche it's pretty crazy is that on the
album or not nah
Lorna but it's like it's gonna be
amazing Wow how did that come up like I
haven't done I'll just give you a job
right now yes you did I need to know how
did this look cuz that's it feels it
feels kind of unexpected
no no you know it's crazy I was with
Nick Huff so shout out to him from her
now yeah yeah and I had this record that
I wrote that was inspired by atmosphere
and slug and I like wrote in it it's
like kind of like a little shout out in
it whatever and he was like yo I you
know I know him like he's a really good
dude whatever and I was like holy [__]
I was like well maybe he could cuz I
didn't know him so I wasn't trying to
like you don't give me a verse like I
was like well maybe he could like speak
at the end and say some like really
prolific at you yeah yeah you know what
I mean so I was like ask him if he wants
to do that and so he hit him and
slugging him back his back and was like
I don't want to talk on it but I'll rap
on it and I was like alright overstep my
bounds you know and so ya know he did it
and he sent back this thing [__]
amazing verse it's like so incredible
and just so it just just what we were
trying to you know get across in the on
that record and we got it and I you know
I got his contact and we hopped on the
headstone man yeah had a great
conversation amazing [__] person with
that being said Merce underrated emcee
of all time were you ever into the felt
were you ever any of the felt albums
with with him it's love you know it was
funny enough is that like I know MERS
but I never really went through the
discography listen that's one I'm gonna
tell you what you gotta listen to emerge
you gotta listen to the tooth fell out
why there's three filled albums now but
the first two felt albums him and
slugged it 100% joint two hours together
we're [__] insane bug has so much
music then you have to [__] with
everything Merce did with [__] 9th
wonder ok Merce 36 out tonight that's
the homie right there yo Fonts hey
underrated rapper a little fun Dylan
Dylan because a lot of people they don't
pay for production as is true this is
true though his albums are insane this
did you are they're amazing this is
[__] some real of R'lyeh being talked
to this is this is incredible and you
know what's so funny like all my fans
are gonna just
watch this okay okay we'll do the top
five producers but give me like the one
producer you think that it's now kini
we're not talking about the timberlands
and the Dre's and the Primo give me like
that one dude who you think doesn't get
mentioned enough that is like next-level
for me I don't want a six six okay this
is me for me it's always no idea but you
can't say no way because there's man but
I always am like no ID and also when it
comes to know either you know a crazy
[__] thing about that
what other producer do you know from the
80s and early 90s who was known for that
that are making records [__] platinum
records with Rihanna and jay-z it's it's
incredible when I think about that not
even what producer what I'm saying like
what's the one producer in your eyes
that like maybe he's a little underrated
that isn't all-time great for me I would
say no ID yeah I think that's always my
default you know I'm gonna be in the cut
though you know there's no purpose I
know I'm definitely her percent yeah
yeah no I it's funny because I met Rob
you know Rob pretty funny engineered a
lot of your phone oh yeah Rob the man I
was backstage at a rock the bells and I
was just traveling up with Rob and we're
like it's like oh you know this very we
were back he's like you know I'm gonna
take you on a nice bus introduce you
know ID it's like thank you but there's
are so many producers that like that uh
I just I mean production is such a weird
I think it's almost like Brian Kidd have
y'all ever heard of ranking I haven't
heard Brian okay let's put it this way
bro Brian Kidd is the [__] man Brian
Kidd is like you know he's like work
with Timbaland sure like that like Brian
kids [__] sounds his [__] is amazing
he did what's the [__] right I'm just
something you guys would know [__] I
need that [__] for J Cole oh I need that
out the first album G how am I
forgetting I [__] love go here not
power trip man this is funny because
like the fans aren't like they know what
it is already in the comments [__]
idiots
your face is this no way I know this
year don't I need that everybody's like
yeah but the [__] bit about it but yeah
what is it yo I'll be pissed off right
now we'll see you in the comments on
YouTube
let me check some stuff okay
okay last time we talked we talked about
porn stars have you ran into any porn
stars since your your fame has gotten on
another level I've never met a porn star
but what the [__] yeah I know what are
you doing in life I live in LA you're uh
you're a similar weather actually that's
a [__] lie
I forget her name but my homey was like
that's I think you know she's dope she
was telling me about her and he was like
yo check out this porn star and I was
like oh cool whatever and then we go to
the [__] with this restaurant and she
like walked right back listen what you
need to do is but I don't want to I'm
gonna porn star [__] I would like a
good beautiful ass you don't want to
porn star but you just want to great I'm
straight I can't be [__] Oh house man
you don't know the [__] guy this
guy's the gentleman I would like to say
at the very least I don't know girl
about like every [__] house you know
just [__] guy he's like he's a
gentleman you speaking for the ladies
all right it's okay to refer to porn
stars in this there's no I was gonna say
no can't get enough Jay Cole can't get
it up okay
well Trey Songz regrets listen you gotta
go childish gambino be he'll be wrapping
the Obi's got skin diamond in his video
childish gambino had a Bela
Hendersonville I understand yeah three
thousand five missions game you know for
something you have to cast a foreign
star okay
and how would it be if iam iam I'll even
their song yes she's retired she's my
friend on Facebook she's married to God
bless you or me up I'm a mother with
your abs I want to look your abs and
everything else but your abs [__] yo
the Sharks might do logic album before
the end of the year Oh without a doubt
okay yeah so be on the lookout for the
album there's no EP coming out he's got
a song coming with slug
I like videogames he loves video games I
just got off the stage that's why I look
for [__] free walk Xbox one
yeah but Xbox there it is go buy a ps4
ps4 cut the check yes please he already
know my bootleg Capcom Shop logic ratbag
billion oh man that that was a good
interview thanks oh yeah it was cool it
was more like shooting the [__]